IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
YOU GUESSED IT UPON THAT FEELING
IN THE AIR.
IT'S "CONSTITUTION DAY,"
CELEBRATING THE SIGNING OF
THE CONSTITUTION BY A BUNCH OF
SWEATY MEN WHO HAD SYPHILIS
AND WORE WIGS.
SO LET'S HONOR OUR COUNTRY'S
RICH HISTORY WITH TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG, #RUINAPRESIDENT.
EXAMPLES MIGHT --
WHAT?
( LAUGHTER )
TOMIS JEFFERSON WOULD WANT US TO
RUIN OUR PRESIDENTS IN A HASHTAG
GAME!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
EXAMPLES WOULD BE BAREBACK
OBAMA.
OR, WILLIAM HOWARD SHAFT.
OR, WARREN G. HARD-ON.
AND NATE DOG.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
YES, BETH.
>> ABRAHAM LINKEDIN.
>> CHRIS: OH GOD YES. PLEASE
STOP SENDING ME REQUESTS FOR
LINKED IN.
ADAM.
>> WILI. AM McKINLEY.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS. NATE.
>> CHESTER B. ARTHUR.
>> CHRIS: CHESTER B. ARTHUR.
YES, WONDERFUL, POINTS.
I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE HIM
BETTER, BUT I'LL ALLOW IT. BETH.
>> WOODROW WILSON PHILLIPS.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
NATE.
>> MARTIN WINDOWLESS VAN BUREN.
>> CHRIS: YES POINTS, BETH.
>> JOHN F'ING KENNEDY.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS. NATE.
>> ELEANOR ROOSEVELT.
>> CHRIS: YEAH. POINTS.
WELL-PLAYED. NATE.
>> GERALD FORD FOCUS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ADAM.
>> WILLIAM HOWARD TAFT MAC AND
CHEESE.
>> CHRIS: OK POINTS!